♪.
WI: FIVE PEOPLE HAVE BN
RESTED AFTER A BORDE PATROL
ENT WAS ASSAUED WHILE TRYINGTO .
U SEE SOME OF THE AGE'SINJURIES.
CP SAID THIS IS THE THIRD
ATTACK O AGENTS IN THESAN YSIDRT
MONTH.
WE HE FORRCTING I.C.E.
DICTOR TOM HOMAN.
YOU'VEEEN THESE SRIES.
OBVISLY IIMATELY INVOLVED
WITH THE BORDER PATROL.ARE YOUUR
SOMETHINLIKEHIS.
>> NO I'M NOT
THE BORDER PATROS JOB IS
INHERELY DANGEROUS.
THEY LOST 142EATHS INHE LINE
OF DUTY.
IT IS DANGEROUS JOB.
IORE THE UNIFORM
IT KNOWHAT ITS LIKE TO BE
OUTHERE.
GOD BLESS HIM HE IECOVERING.
WHAT IS SHAMEFUL THE BEN
MINISTRATION MAD THEIR JOBWHICHH
MOREANGEROUS.
BORD PATROL SAY0, 50% OF
MANPOWER ISOT ON THE LINE,
PROCESSING FILY UNIAKING
CARE OF THEM.
THAT MEANS HAL THE BORDER
PATROL UTS ARE NOTN THE
LINE.
BACK UP IS 20 MINUTES AWAY, HF
HOUR 45 MINUTES AWAY.
THE CARTEL KNOWHIS.
THEYNOW HALF THE BDER PATROLAGE.
TH MOVE DGS AND BAD PEOPLE.
A LOT OF ALI SMUGGRS CARRY
WEAPONS.ALMOST A NARCOTICSMUGGLS
CARRY WEAPS.
SO THE INCIDENTS INVOLVING
FIREARMS AND FIGS A
SKYROCKETING BECAU OF THENATUREE
BORDER.
WILL: TWO FASNATING STATS YOU
GA US.
FIRST OF ALL HALF OF BORDER
PATROL AGENTS A CALLED OFF THE
LINE ESSENALLY INVOLVED IN A
HUMANITARIAN EFFORIN PROVIDI
CA TOLLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THE OTHER ST, 142 AGENTS LOST
THEIR LIVES IN E LINE OF DUTY.TE
PERI, WHEN I A YOU ABOAT, HOW, R
PAOL ANT LOSE THEIR LIFE?
SHOOTINGS.VEHICLECCIDENTS.THER.
SOME FELL OFF THEIR CLIFFS.
THEREAVE BEEN 10 COVID DEATHS,
IN T LINE OF DUTY COVID
ATHS, PUT INHE POSITION,
COVIDOMING ACROSS THE BORDE
THSANDS A DAY, BIDEN
MINISTRATION I IGNING TLE
42 FOR FAMILY,DULTS, PEOPLE OF
OTR PAR OF COUNTRY
THEY NOTNLY DEAL WITH VIOLENCE
BUTHE COVID ACRS THE BORDER.
DEN ADMINISTRION IS LETTINGPEOPH
COVID.
IT A DANGEROUS JOB.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRION MAKES
IT ME DANGEROUS.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN SND O THE
NE WHEN YOU AND ME ARE
SLEEPING.
MIDDLEF THE NIGHT, 3:0IN THE
MORNIN A CENSOR GOES OFF I
WALKING TRAIL
THEY WILL GO 2 MINUTES LATER
OFF TT CENR, TAKE WHATEVE
COMES.
ISTOMEONE FOR A BETRIFE,
OR A HEAVILY AED DRUG
SMGLER.
THEY DON KNOW.
THEY TAKE TS ON WHILE THE REST
OF THE MEN AND WOMENRE
SLEEPING.
THESE AREHE FINEST MEN AND
WOMEN.
WHAT HPENED TO THEOUNG LADY,
WHAT HAPPENED, TOHE PEOPLE DO
EVERY DAY 24/7.
WI: THIS VEO SHOWS ARREST OF
ILLEGALMMIGRANTS HIDING IN
STORM DINAGE SYSTEM IN TEXAS
I DON'T KW IF WE HAVE VIDEO UP
ON THE SCREEN.
10 OF THEM, DOWN IN THE STO
DRAINOMING OUT.
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK ATHIS, T,
AT DO YOU TAKEAWAYROM THAT?
>>GAIN THE CRIMINAL CARTELS
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE O T
HUMANITARIAN CRIS.
THEY SEND LAR GROUPS OF FAMILY
AND CHILDREN THROUGH O PART T
E ALL THE BORDER PATROL UP, S
THEY SNE OTHS WHO DON'T WT
TO GET CAUGHT THROUGH OTHERPART.
CARTELS MAKE MEY TO SMUGGLE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIESO SMUGG
PEOPLE IN.THEY SMUGEL PEOPLE TOL
DESTINATIONN NEW YORK.
THAT GROUP PICKED UP, TAKENO A
SA HOUSE.
WAIT FOR PAY-OFFELATIVES OR
MEBODY ELSE WE THEM MON,
KE THEIR WAY TO CHIGO.THATS WAYR
MONEY.
THIS IS NOT JUST HANITARIAN
CRISIS.
SMUGGLERS A I A GREAT
BUSINESS OF SMUGGLING PPLE TO
THE INTERIOR OFHE UNITED
ATES, TO THE FINALSTINATION.MAN.
OVER 90,000 FENTANYLEATHSN
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE O THE
BORD C